okay let's do it
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your absolutely
favorite podcast you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right okay we did it
uh that's that's the fun part of the
show i guess whatever hey welcome back
to roofing with griffin guys we got a
special one well
whatever i don't know why you even say
that we go to the spiritual one it's
just the same one regular old damn
podcast this is what i do they're all
special i guess
rachel's back so make sure you stay
tuned for that um
talk about thanksgiving had a great
thanksgiving i made the turkey myself
we're gonna discuss that
um but anyways thanks for watching
richard with griffin and i appreciate
you guys uh
being here uh once again you know it's
been a while a few weeks you know this
is weird covet times and i know i'm just
like
exhausted the subject of coving so we're
not even gonna get into that but first i
want to say thanks for watching and
make sure you catch me daily on twitch
that's eric griffin gaming so make sure
you check that out
and i appreciate you guys being here you
know i've gotten some like so many
different messages and so much stuff so
it's like
ugh you know it's like enough already
about it
you know ellie just shut down again you
know what i mean so we're shut
they're shut down we can't even go eat
outside at restaurants i don't know what
all these like shows that are going on i
think they're all going to stop
everything's going to stop again because
the cases are rising so cases are rising
and it's like you know it is what it is
uh
and we'll see it may even rise even more
because people got together during
thanksgiving so
we'll see what happens you know say i'm
not
i'm not an expert i don't know what's
going on i just like to pose some
questions and you know
all these responses like i got like some
of the responses like i got this really
condescending response from somebody
somebody just me you know it's like
you know well people act the way they
act when they send you messages because
of all the holes in your arguments like
like any he calls himself a fan but he's
just it just was like
it's such a rude message people don't
know how they sound
but i don't i don't care regardless it
doesn't even it doesn't even it doesn't
even matter so we're not we're not going
to go into it just
all i'll say is this is please you know
stay safe be socially distant
uh let's you know let's do our best to
stay safe stay healthy do the best you
can
uh are we handling it the right way i'm
just
no we're not and that's why cases are
rising and that's why
all these things that are happening are
happening right now so we'll see
all right anyways happy thanksgiving
guys uh you know i hope you had a great
thanksgiving like i said rachel's going
to come on and here and i'm going to
talk about what
how we did for thanksgiving and you know
i look forward to that
uh i guess briefly we'll talk because i
haven't talked about this in a while but
i want to go see my mom
you know i didn't see her on
thanksgiving day because it was just
the timing of it because they live an
hour away from me so it was hard to go
see but i saw her yesterday
i believe it was yesterday whatever day
it was that i saw her and it was it was
hard
you know my mom's got mild dementia but
it's just i don't know why i say mild
it's just dementia you know
regardless whatever it is you know and
uh
i mean it's a funny disease really if
you step back and just look at like
the things that are happening you know
because this new thing when my so
my mom got in the car because i couldn't
really go inside to where they are i'm
not supposed to even though i could have
snuck in but you don't really want to do
that
you know so she gets in the car we go on
a drive
so you know again my mom thinks her
grandmother's alive so
you know even though her grandmother's
been there for 40 years
you know what i mean 40 and you know
it's a really strange thing too
she was talking to me the other day
about her
uncle her grandmother's son you know
and she was saying like oh yeah i
remember him and but she was like oh he
must be long dead
she's telling me this she's like yeah if
he was alive he would be like 99 years
old
he must be long like he's dead
she can logically understand that her
uncle's dead
but her her uncle's mother
is still alive you know what i mean like
it's
it's like she you know it that's it
it's hard not you know the thing you
have to do is you cannot respond
it's so hard for me because i'm such an
[ __ ] you know what i mean
i'm just being honest about it i'm a
comic so i just my thing is to like
point things out so we're driving in the
car you know
we're an oxnard and we're driving and
we're driving you know that's her new
thing is to like
she keeps going we pass a house right
she goes eric that house
that's the house i went with with my
grandmother when i first came to
california
that house right there i'm like okay
like you it you know what i mean like
it's like in your man i'm trying to tell
myself eric just let this go
you know what i mean just let it go
you know she's six more blocks same
thing eric see that house
that's the house that my grandmother
brought you know she did it four times
on the fourth one i was like you just
pointed out three houses how many houses
did you go visit you know and i
shouldn't have done that
i mean i just i'm laughing about it
because it's just like i just can find
humor in anything but
it you know it's hard you know what i
mean that's how i deal with it you know
but it's just like
and i shouldn't have done that because i
could tell that she was like i could
tell that
there was a moment where she even
realized she was like oh i did kind of
point out two other houses you know but
then she just oh never mind you know and
i just like i just
let me just ignore this and try to like
enjoy this time
i spend with my mom you know and it's
hard i find myself i do avoid it
um and i shouldn't i don't know if you
have if you have a family member with
dementia but you know it's like i don't
have a lot of family my mom's like one
of the last of my blood relatives that i
actually talk that that that you know i
have a relationship with
so it's hard to um to deal with but i
have to just make the effort you know
just getting her in the car and driving
around especially just for my step-dad's
sake because he needs a break
i'm sure you know i can't the man is the
salt of the earth man
so kudos to him i love him dearly for
what he's going through right now and he
is never going to have to worry about
anything
as long as i'm alive you know what i
mean uh
just for this bond that we share now
because of
uh this horrible disease so
my you know my thoughts and prayers go
out to everybody that is dealing with
dementia and alzheimer's and all those
all these types of uh these kind of
brain diseases and
hopefully knock on wood we find a way to
like cure it
stop it you know so if you if you donate
to like your local whatever so make sure
you do that so that was that you know i
don't want to just
start you know starting off on a downer
but it is what it is guys you know
that's part of my life
i talk about my life on this podcast and
that's what it is it's riffing with
griffin
all right other thing uh that was
happening is like you know they had the
big fight you know the tyson uh
uh roy jones jr fight listen i'm i don't
like fights
i don't like fighting i don't watch it
because i'm just not into it i don't
like watching
i just it's too violent for me i barely
like football if it wasn't for
fantasy sports i wouldn't even watch
football it's just too violent my buddy
eric coke he's been on the podcast
i don't like watching him fight because
i just feel like
one wrong hit one wrong kick one wrong
anything and then what he's paralyzed
or he he'll never be the same and it's
just i hate seeing that so i
do not like fighting so i didn't watch
it you know
but what i did watch was you know
i saw on instagram um
they had the undercard which was jake
paul and nate robinson former nba
basketball player nate robinson little
dude you know he was he won the dunk
contest
he's you know a few different teams but
he's just a dynamic athlete
so let's just look at it here's from
jake paul's instagram you know it comes
in jab
punch jab uppercut right hook
knocked him the [ __ ] out
like bye bye bye
and it was not good you know what i mean
it was not good
it that that knockout do you see that
that sucker was
[Music]
man and so i looked it up because i
wanted to find out do they have
beef or something it turns out they
didn't even really have beef other than
nate robinson just called him out you
know jake paul brother of logan paul
they're social media stars
you know they've they've parlayed their
fame uh their online presence into
a multi-million dollar business okay the
guys are filthy rich
all right you look up highest paid
people on
uh youtube they're in the top five all
the time
okay the guys make a lot of both of the
brothers they make a lot of money they
have a successful podcast
you know they're just personalities and
and then you know they know they're not
liked
they know that people and so they got
into fighting which is
also all it's doing is generating more
money for them because they have these
like
exhibition fights and then boom here
they are
you know making money they're in a tyson
undercard fight
you know um it's crazy so anyways they
didn't really have a beef other than
nate robinson called him out
like i want to fight you know because
i'm a world-class
athlete and you know and he was you know
first of all basketball players are some
of the most they're the greatest
athletes on the planet earth
playing in the nba just just physical
specimens you're talking about dudes
that are six
five physically cut they run fast they
jump high they're strong
i mean to be in the nba you have to be
such a physical specimen
so and i get it he was a short guy short
stature guy but
he could jump out there he was he won
the dunk contest
he just was like and a phenomenal
athlete
and so he thought like i'm and i'm and
i'm sure there's a racial element too of
like i'ma beat this white boy up you
know what i mean
he got his ass beat and the reason why
is the complete and utter
disrespect lack of respect for the
art form of boxing
that's what this was people out here
think
they just putting on mitts and they
gonna go in there
and then and it's just oh i'm gonna be
able to do this nah man
listen i don't fight i'm not a fighter
but i have done a few boxing workouts
before covert i was going to this boxing
gym um to
you know i went to glove works in santa
monica
glove works it's actually partly owned
now by king batch
a buddy of mine he invested in it it's a
great workout boxing is a
full body great intense workout but like
i ain't a fighter
i'm not sparring with anybody you know
what i mean i'm just swinging my hands
and hitting stuff
and then when like you're sparring when
you're hit you know when when they're
training you and they got their mitts
up they're actually doing this too so
they're moving forward while you're
punching
when you get that connect it feels and
sounds and makes you feel powerful
because when you hit that mit and
they're hit you know it makes a sound
and you like oh i'm ready to throw some
hands you think like i wish somebody
would test me
but trust me you're not really doing
anything
so like i remember the first time i ever
did a boxing workout i don't know i've
talked about this on
another podcast but i don't care this is
my podcast i do whatever [ __ ] i want
anyways
so craig robinson buddy of mine he
started to do boxing he was like losing
weight he always goes in these phases
where he loses weight so every two years
craig robinson loses a lot of weight
gains it back loses a lot of weight
gains about you know what i mean because
i get his heart at our age
you know you got it it's hard to stick
with it you know but he was on the
boxing kick
so i go with him and uh the trainer is
this old grizzly black dude
he might he might be like 61. you know
you talking like come on eric
get your hands up boy get your hands up
you know just just a a trickster i
remember the
i remember he was supposed to bring
gloves from me and he forgot
and he tried to blame it on craig he's
that kind of guy like i told you
remember i told you you're supposed to
bring it he's that kind of dude
so first first thing we do is i have 10
pound weights and i'm walking on a
treadmill on an incline
and i actually use that when i go on the
road and i want to get some exercise i
go into the
hotel gym and i get their weights and i
get on the treadmill and i walk with the
weights and then i'll even do curls
while i'm walking i try to get like
that kind of workout in you know so this
was a hard workout you know
you know because i hadn't i was fat
fatter than i am you know
now and i do that and then you know we
do some some some drills
and then it's time to get in the ring
for three minutes and i gotta tell you
that was some of the that was the
hardest workout i've ever done
that three minutes in that ring you know
and this dude he got his you know he's
he's moving around he's like hit the ba
hit it
you know i'm hitting the thing i'm
trying to hit i'm trying to move i'm
trying not to trip over my own feet
you know and then he's like hit it but
keep your hands up you kept saying that
to me keep your hands up
keep your hands up you know and i
wouldn't do it and then he cocked oh
hit me in the face pal just tapped me in
the face and i was like
[ __ ] you know i initially i was
like you don't hit me in the face i'm
trying to work out you know
and then but you they keep your hands up
you know what i mean
and then so you lock in i remember
getting locked in you know
and it was so hard threw like four or
five punches and
it was i was exhausted
i got i after that workout i had
so much more respect for boxers
their uh endurance and
what it takes to be in a ring for that
long and throw that many punches you
know you hear him throwing like
50 punches thrown or something and i'm
like what
i don't even know how to do so they're
so in shape
at the end of the thing i remember him
saying you know it's like i'm in there
for three minutes
it's the last like 20 seconds and he
says finish the fight like you were in
the streets
you know and then i was like this is
what i did i was like
and then bing bing bing and i was like
i'm out i'm out i'm done bye
bye bye everybody bye
heart and i it was until recently that i
came back into it
you know before kovit i was like you
know going and going there
because it's that sucker it's just it's
a tough workout so my point is though
even i get how people go do boxing
workouts
and because of the nature of it and
you're hitting the bag and you're
getting out all this aggression
or you think you're ready to box you
know
you think you can actually you step into
the ring now man
you can and that's what we learned in
this right here
nate robinson got embarrassed he should
be embarrassed
it was it was embarrassing i was sad for
him but
for him to think just because he was a
world-class athlete
oh now i'm going to jump into the ring
with somebody who
obviously trains jake paul and his
brother they
this is what they've been working on now
for you for a few years now
is you know being amateur boxers you
know and fighters
so this guy he put him to school
man you know it's like have more respect
for
the footwork for the art of
defense and boxing uh how to throw your
punches how to use your body
how to move like it is so much more than
just two guys
swinging at each other trying to hurt
each other like boxing is a beautiful
sport
after you try to do it one time you'll
figure it out so
i thought that that was just it was it
was just terrible i mean
you know we should look at it just look
at it again i probably you know i
probably i've already been showing it
over and over again
you know right here just like how just
devastating that was but it's like come
on man whoo he you know he he
he set us back
it's like good night brother good night
so there's that
my thoughts thoughts and prayers to nate
robinson in his uh
boxing career other thing uh
what i wanted to like just bring up is
like you know i've been having these
different thoughts and feelings about
sex workers
i know that's weird but i remember being
on this podcast
uh guys we [ __ ] um i forgot the girls
names but it's a great podcast and we
were talking about
we were talking about prostitutes and
strippers and things like that
it was a very polarizing conversation
because i got so many
the most interaction i've ever gotten
from a podcast appearance actually
so it was like 50 of the women would hit
me up and be like i totally agree with
what you were saying
then the other 50 to be like you're an
[ __ ] you don't understand you don't
understand what sex worker you know what
this is a legitimate business and all
this kind of stuff right so cut to now
years later and i'm thinking about it
because of kovit
i actually have a different feeling
about
you know how i feel about sex work and
what
and people doing it first let me just
say this i'm old school
i come from an era where like they used
to have on hbo there was this show
called i think it was called hookers
at the point or hookers on the stroll or
it was something they had like a few of
them where it was like hookers
so when you think of sex work in my
generation
you think a hooker you think of a street
walking
drug using abused emotionally
emotionally just broke down person
hooker okay four different kids
you know just in the system you know
what i mean been to jail you know it's
like
there's this sort of demonized negative
stigma you have
about prostitution when you're my age
you know because that's
what is you know that's what it is so
you know what are you supposed to you
know what are you supposed to do but cut
two now things are different
but i will say i'm not gonna sit here
and act like
you know i think that this is okay for
everyone because i don't think that it
is
but i don't think that we should
demonize it the way we've been doing the
way
i have in my own head you know because
cut two now
i have many friends who these female
friends who like because of because of
kova they lost their job or
are you know they a only fan's account
and here they are making good money you
know paying their bills
you know so it's different but
look we can me halfway because i don't
want you to sit here and cause there's a
lot of people and i don't want to start
the discussion
within the comments and people talking
about like what are your feelings about
sex work you know
are you one of these people that thinks
like it's a terrible thing and it you
know it should not it should be taken
out of society or are you somebody
that's like hey
people are monetizing their look and
their bodies and you know in a safe way
and they are making money off that and
they should be allowed to do that
because how is it any different from
swimsuit models i mean look
you look on instagram man you go to
reels you know like because i
like follow rachel and i follow a couple
of her friends and and
you know and and just being a dude you
know you see a girl with big titties and
you're like who's this
all of a sudden now your reels that they
suggest
it's all the same type of thing and i
can't believe how many
countless these young women you know
these you know 18 to 25 year old women
who are just
they just dancing first of all they
can't dance i don't know what the hell
are they doing they can't dance they in
bikinis doing these suggestive
sexy dances and it's just there like
do they understand that this is for
everyone that every single person
in the entire world who is on instagram
can look at you or tick tock
can see you dancing like a like a
stripper
like you know it's like do they know
that so it's like okay there it is right
there and then a lot of those people
have decided well let me take this as a
commercial and you know hey come see
more
and pay me for it so i'm starting to
have a different feeling about it i
start to go like there is
go do you monetize it's like when i go
it's like i take my fame from being a
comedian and an actor and i
take it to twitch and i'm playing video
games and people are watching me play
video games
that's me monetizing my personality so
these women and men too because there's
a lot of like there's a lot of men on
and only fans too making making money so
it's like
straight and gay you know they're out
there just doing doing a due diligence
so
here we are is it why we have this
stigma this like demonizing of people
who are monetizing their sexuality
so i'm i feel different i'm feeling
differently about it especially when you
know people you talk to them you know
there's female comics man there's female
comics out here who got only fans
accounts
because you know they weren't getting a
lot of spots or or you know they were on
the come up
you know they're beautiful and they're
like okay well this is i gotta pay bills
you know i don't have a regular job i
was you know people doing odd jobs and
doing different things to try to get by
to try to be an actor entertainer and
they decided hey
i got to go into this you know you know
it's like
i don't know if we should fault them for
that so i'm i'm starting to change my
feel for it you know
it's just at the same time though it's
like let's not but let's let's meet
halfway because don't act like
if your younger sister your young cousin
your young
uh you know young female in your life
comes to you and says hey guess what i
want to be a prostitute
you're not going to be like well let me
show you how to do it no you know why i
would hope you wouldn't do that
so let's not act like this is an adult
industry
so don't act like it's something that
you could just talk to or say to anyone
or
feel good about it if you're talking to
like young girls you know what i mean so
let's let's be real about that but at
the same time though
you go the world is different i mean
getting old
i realize isn't about necessarily
getting old and you know
getting you get crotchety and old no no
what happens is you lose touch with
what's
happening because the world is ever
evolving ever changing ever moving
music culture things change and when
you're older you
you know you get stuck in like the ways
of like oh well this is how i know it to
be
and then the world is like well we've
actually evolved and changed and the
world's this way now
and you know the ones that can't go oh
let me grasp this let me figure out what
this means and let me try to understand
it
that's people that can like thrive and
stay relevant you know and i want to be
one of those people
i want to stay relevant i don't want to
just sit here and be like
oh you know back in the day my day we
did this that you know it's like
no you can't do that so you know with
the with technology
the way it is advanced it has made the
the people in a more safe way for people
to like be involved in that type of work
i mean i i used to i've talked about
this before but i liken sex work to
a casino you know you put a casino in a
neighborhood
and look it makes a lot of money it's
fun it's providing jobs
there are some there's upside the
downside is there's a lot of crime and
seediness around casinos
pawn shops open up and there's a lot of
like lives are ruined i mean there's a
lot of bad things that come with that
there's good and bad i think it's the
same thing with sex work
my girl likes to listen to all these
podcasts uh
and like she follows tick-tockers and
there's like there's a few strippers on
tick tock
they'll come and tell their story and i
was watching with her and this girl was
talking about like she was like well you
know
you know i couldn't make 900 a night i
could just keep going but she was like i
just had a hard night
the men were super aggressive
the thing she was talking about this the
psychological effect of
because i'm not cause strip club same
thing strip clubs they're
that is just a seedy ass business it's a
cd environment it breeds
it breeds like this sort of like
objectifying you know it really
amplifies the objectifying and how of
of the sex worker in a way that i just
don't like it i've never been a fan of
strip clubs
uh you know it's just i don't like it
you know and when you hear it you talk
to a stripper
you know they'll say things like oh i
hate men they hate men because of the
men they go to strip clubs and
they don't you know they had bad
experiences because of what happened in
that strip you know so
i'm just saying so there is that side of
it but at the same time it's like
you know is there the internet is making
it
a safer because you know a safer way to
be a sex worker because you have like
the cam work and
you know you you have a if you are
if you are selling yourself if you are
having sex for money
you know it's illegal in most places but
you know you're still doing it
people people getting by um
now there's a more way to like track
track yourself more way to like you know
maybe you fake you maybe they're
facetiming with the person first and
being like hey you know
you could barely get a better sense a
better gauge of like is this going to be
a safe
situation i mean i don't know i just
think it's different
i mean because i know that there's still
cd back back door back alley sex [ __ ]
going on
you know but i can't think that all of
it is like that
i guess is the point i'm trying to make
it's not all like that there is
some you know you have to start looking
at it and being like hey
we got to stop demonizing this and
making people feel shitty about it
you know maybe we just need to legalize
it you know in the same way or
decriminalize it it's a thing too
like decriminalize i think that's
instead of saying legalize you
decriminalize i stop making things that
people are doing
criminal activity uh but you know again
it leads to
there it is surrounded by child
pornography and surrounded by
uh you know sex trafficking and and all
that stuff i mean that's
that that goes hand in hand with with
sex work it's it's it's in the same
you know you know i mean it's in the
same book you know it's in the same book
so that's why you know there are certain
feelings in
about it so but anyways i guess i don't
know why i'm even talking about this but
i'm just saying
i'm starting to have a different feeling
about it because listen i don't
i don't ever mind being wrong about
something you know
i like to pose questions like when i was
talking about the covet stuff i'm just
posing the question i'm just asking
a simple question you know and people
just attack me they just attack and
attack and attack because they like to
hear themselves talk
they like to hear themselves they like
to like they have their point they're
trying to make and they're not
scientists none of you [ __ ] are
scientists you know most of you you know
there are a couple scientists
him yeah thank you but you did it very
respectfully the rest of these clowns
they just like
they're just some people that like
hearing cnn talking points you know
you're all talking point people then you
want to hit me up like the holes in your
argument there's a reason why it's like
you know what
this ain't the podcast for you homie so
but at the same time though you know you
hit me with some facts and some
information
i'm gonna add to my collect my my
knowledge and be like oh well i have
this different feeling about it like
somebody sent me
speaking of somebody sent me an article
about um there was something about like
some side effects in the coronavirus are
affecting certain people a certain way
and it's like it made me feel oh well
there's a way that's a way you justify
hey we have to you know keep things shut
down regardless of what it does
financially to people because we don't
know
how this thing is going to affect people
right so that's me
me taking that information i'm going
okay now that i understand you know what
i mean
but it's like i'm not sitting here like
anyways i don't even want to go into
that anymore because
you got you guys pissed me off but
anyways again i'm not
opposed to learning something new and i
just want to evolve and i want to stay
fresh and relevant so
let's have a discussion so you know what
i mean hit me up in the chat
hit me up on instagram hit me up and
make make your call
i like to look at the comments when
they're not troll garbage
you know you have your thoughts because
i got some when i talked about moving
and i talked about renting versus owning
i got so much great information from
people and
good great comments and great thoughts
so i appreciate that so let's continue
it here with this
are you a person that is completely
against sex work or are you a person
are you pro-sex worker you think that
you know should be like they should have
more rights and freedoms and they should
be
treated like just like any other
profession right
so i'm starting to lean more in that in
that way it's still nuanced it's still a
broad subject it's still a lot like i
said there's still a lot of negativity
around it
let's not fool ourselves like let's be
real let's be 100 okay i'm not gonna sit
up here and be like
this is all fun and dandy because if you
were if you were speaking at a
if you were speaking at a a conference
about female business
you know female entrepreneur business
people you know and and then there was
like a
a grammar school class there full of you
know 13 year old girls
i'm sure you wouldn't sit there and be
like well this is what i do for a living
you know what i mean because you'd be
like oh this is inappropriate for this
for what's happening right now so don't
act like it's you know
let's not act like it's like like this
100 thing
right it's nuanced and i'm leaning more
towards
i am telling myself you got to stop
demonizing these people that are doing
this thing just because i have these
feelings that are old school
so anyway that's that um
so up next uh my girl's back my fiance
uh the beautiful rachel's here to talk
to us about
thanksgiving crystals and how i need to
shower
thanks for watching get a sound check
hello
hello hello hello
[Laughter]
are you in you're in you sound it sounds
good to you
well oh you don't even know because you
can't yeah oh you're good
you look very nice thank you you look
very lovely as usual
outfit change number two yes you would
not i said
you look fine you know she was like no i
want to put on my shirt because i wanted
to show my crystals
this is my crystal shirt i don't
what does that even mean i just remember
that last time i wore the shirt that i
was wearing
previously before this shirt that i'm
wearing currently
i would sit down and it would wrench up
in the
middle and it made me look very chubby
listen to me and so i thought this shirt
just looks better when i sit down and
everyone understands that okay they have
a shirt that looks better when they sit
down
let me tell you something i don't care
what that shirt does
there isn't a shirt that's gonna make
you look chubby
chubby
no it's not even that i feel chubby it's
just the shirt makes me look chubby
the shirt makes you look chill okay all
right
[Laughter]
we'll just go with it and then move on
has that like always been a thing where
like
like when you go oh i feel fat or like
oh my god this is fat like
are you aware like how thin you are to
like say a real fat person
do you ever think about that or it's
just your own like i feel fat so if i
feel fat i'm fat
yeah i think it's your own personal or
at least my own personal range of
fatness
so like within my life span of what i've
been
from like gaining weight to losing
weight to like
in between like i'm at my
your fattest right now maybe
i think high school i might have been
the same
yeah it was just that like the bread
[Laughter]
like for a while for a while he stopped
eating bread like
when i started when i first met you i
didn't eat bread
bread you did though on special occasion
like once a year oh wednesday when we
would go to a burger place once a year
okay well
who are you lying to me right now it's
not true you ate bread all the time
okay before you i guess no but you still
were always like i don't want to eat
dairy i don't want to eat bread i don't
know what eat cheese
it wasn't like you did you know but
every restaurant i ever take you to
you eat bread okay i like bread
[Laughter]
that's why i feel a little chubby
it's not bread like
uh yeah all right i'm just i
was always curious is like because i
guess it's all relative to whoever
is the person talking i mean we all feel
fat
you know it was just thanksgiving happy
thanksgiving i know you she wanted to
talk about being fat anymore um happy
thanksgiving we had a great
rachel and i had our first like we did
thanksgiving ourselves
we cooked well we didn't cook everything
because rachel saw her mom at the market
but
we i made a turkey right
right i mean i think it was the last
holiday we spent with my family
you turned to me right after and you're
like
i want to do the next thanksgiving yeah
and so i remembered
and so i kept reminding you like i think
we're going to do thanksgiving should we
invite people i know and then corona
happens i know the good thing we didn't
invite
anyone we had enough we could we would
we could have served maybe three more
people right
yeah and rachel made some delicious
sides she made a
purple sweet potato sweet potato thing
with marshmallows on top and pineapple
yeah it was so good sliced in there and
then
um i made some green bean casserole
with uh bacon yeah and then
um what else do we have
well we had my turkey the most important
part of the meal let's get to that
that was so good yeah i really you guys
it was unbelievably
juicy it was the best turkey
i could have asked for you know but i i
learned something i learned some things
that i will do different next time but
it really made me feel like oh i want to
cook a chicken i want to cook like you
know like a whole chicken in the oven
you know so
and then we're moving so that's going to
be like a whole i can't wait to do a
kitchen with griffin in this new kitchen
it's going to because i'm tired of
people clowning me about my kitchen
you know and rachel talking smack about
my about my place and then my kitchen
so now we're finally getting our own
place but let's continue to talk about
thanksgiving and then we can go into
like
your all that stuff but um okay because
we and then our we invited our friends
miles and amanda
came over amanda is rachel's model
friend and then
you know miles is he's a really cool
dude you know
well he's her husband oh that's true
that's what they're married
that's what they can do right i don't
know what i'm talking about yeah they're
married
don't act like they're your friends i
know i know i know it's like my friend
got with her friend no
it's their friend you know so they came
over you know it was
that was it we just had two people over
with us and you know
we had a nice little cause it was like
it was thanksgiving yeah um amanda made
macaroni
and shrimp mac and cheese pumpkin pie
and they brought
did she make the pumpkin pie yeah did
she
well we'll say she made it
it was good though so i don't know how
everybody else's thanksgiving was but i
think we had i think it was like i felt
you know what i felt i felt like a like
a real adult like i was like oh i'm
i'm i'm i'm providing thanksgiving
dinner for
my loved ones and and my friends you
know i just felt like that it just felt
good i was nervous about that turkey but
you know we did it right oh the day
before you're not even
telling people that you were freaking
out saying don't do it let's cancel it
yeah like can they not come i know i
really would like why did you invite
people
like what were you thinking because i
wasn't sure and i was like
frantically cleaning up yeah rachel fake
let's just be honest about it she don't
like to clean up she you know she's just
me
we're both kind of messy you know which
is like this the only way you can
actually
work because like if you have a really
clean person and a really messy person
those people they're gonna have her come
to a head so we're messy until
one of her friends comes over and then
all of a sudden rachel is cleaning
well it's kind of like a messy organized
situation like we know where everything
is but it's a little messy that's fair
that's fair we could clean up a little
bit more but anyway she straightened up
and all this stuff and then they came
over but i was worried about the turkey
because then rachel bought the turkey
she went to where did you get that from
well okay so i was too scared to go to
whole foods the first day
i was just like it's going to be crazy
there's not going to be anything left
like there's going to be long lines at
the register
and outside well wait wait but wait
before that though
remember i was looking online to see
well let me just order a turkey dinner
right we were trying to order a
pre-made yeah yeah okay a week before
thanksgiving
a pickup turkey like it was going to be
and ham
yeah i wanted to get a ham already made
sides yeah we would we
but no we made dinner pretty much we
couldn't find it anywhere
no it's all sold out all sold out the
only thing available were ham dinners
and we i wanted to get the ham dinner
but at the same time i was like you
can't just have ham
thanksgiving well i started really
looking into it
and they come frozen eric i don't know
if you know this but
they shipped they ship it to you frozen
and then you and then you have to like
pretty much bake it yourself anyway
so wow like i'm a baker i'm gonna do
that
you might as well go to the grocery
store i know whole foods bakes it for
you
and then it's like already hot yeah they
could serve
but we but there's a waiting list for
that we didn't get on any list
right so i thought air one was gonna be
a
good idea yeah because she's so fancy
she got to go to now that i was fancy it
was just like
one is fancy it's a fancy like
bougie-ass stored at
the overpriced store okay i know that
but
[Laughter]
but they just have a really high quality
produce okay and i was thinking if
if i don't even get the turkey there at
least i'll get some vegetables there
that's what i was thinking so i got some
organic purple yams
i got organic potatoes i oh yeah
mashed potatoes with gravy and
um you bought all the spices from there
i bought all the vegetables yeah all the
spices
um yeah rachel bought oh no no i didn't
buy the spices from there i couldn't
find all the spices because where'd you
get the spices because they were like
we like on the ingredients list it's
like
herbs like
like thyme uh
basil i just couldn't find it in air one
because it's not like labeled and i
didn't know
really what they look like yeah you know
it's just yeah rachel
rachel and our brother are getting on my
case because i call time
thyme it's spelled t h y m
fine okay we're just like no one told
you
[Laughter]
it's like why it should be fine we're
not mad we just want
to help you the correct way to say it
there's already a time okay
whatever when i say what time is it so
anyway i see these little turkeys
and already pre-packaged in the
refrigerator section so i like
saw some guy walking right past me and i
was like excuse me do you think this
would
um serve for people he's like adults
no and i was like oh
and he was like i don't cook and i was
like neither do i
and he was like let me get someone to
help you so he got he
he was like oh we just got the turkeys
in too so he's like giving me the like
oh you got the frog
turkey yeah and so like the guy from the
back you know who's like
getting off his shift and so like he's
like yeah we just got some in let me get
them
and so he was like how big do you want
and i'm like
big enough for four people four grown
people four grown ass people
and so they come back with this 18 pound
turkey
they put it in my cart and
i just look at it i take a few pictures
i think i sent you a picture
then i sent amanda a picture
and then i was like okay at that point
it's like whatever yeah i was like what
am i gonna do
like i think this is too big for just
the four of us
and then so i like went back to a
different guy because the other guy
left already and i was like you know i
think this turkey won't fit in my
oven do you have a smaller size like
maybe like a five pound smaller turkey
five pound that wouldn't have been
it would that wouldn't have been enough
turns out no like
it was an 18 pound turkey so i was
thinking you wanted to go from 18 to
five
no just five pounds less like oh like a
ten pound turkey yeah
oh oh right i mean that's eight pounds
less but yeah yeah something like that
and so they're like no all of the other
turkeys
um are already for
other people oh so you have to grab it
literally the only turkey available
you also got the the recipe she actually
got the recipe online oh and then the
guy tells me that the wait list closed a
week ago
yeah i don't know what we were thinking
this was a week this was a monday
we were thanksgiving when we went and
did game night at amanda and miles place
was when we decided hey let's have
thanksgiving together and that was like
over like how long ago was that and we
didn't even think about like oh we'll be
able to get to turkey
like you know we'll be able to do this
like you know three two or three days
ahead of time but we didn't
but rachel found a great recipe online
you know
and you bought she actually bought all
the ingredients and stuff
for me to cook it so she had like
fresh rosemary fresh oh yeah then i go
to whole foods for that stuff oh and i
bought all
they had all of the the packets of like
herbs and stuff basil and yeah so it was
like that stuff it was thyme rosemary
right available for everyone it was
great yeah
and then i ended up running into my mom
looking for i think i was like in the
vegetable soup aisle
and i was like again asking a worker
being like um where is the already made
cranberry sauce
and then my mom like hurt must have like
heard my voice and turned around she's
like rachel
she's like i'm making cranberry sauce
and homemade i'll make you some and i
was like oh
can you also make stuffing and she was
like yeah
okay but she didn't like her mom's stuff
it was it she put pickle in the stuffing
i didn't like it i liked your mom's
stuffing but we have a lot of it left
but i like
cranberry sauce if anybody wants
somebody to send you some of this stuff
and it was good so but like anyways like
rachel you
she found all the the ingredients she
bought all the ingredients and then left
it in the fridge for me to do it
and it was like so scary at first so i
what i did was i have my little chopper
and so i
chopped up all of the stuff i even you
were you were gone you had to go to work
but i called your mom and your brother
because like i don't know if it was the
rosemary
it was rosemary thyme and i forgot what
the other one is but it was like a
you know a branch and it had very little
leaves on it
right i don't remember i forgot which
one that was but i wasn't sure if did
you just put the whole branch in or you
take the leaves off
right you probably just take the leaves
off that's what your mom and dad
michael both said but the other one the
soft one you could put the thing in like
the rosemary
is so soft you could just put it in but
this one was like these little leaves
so i was like you know so i put it all
in my chopper with a bunch of garlic
i ground that all up then i got some uh
the soy butter whatever the the the
butter from whole foods that's non-dairy
and i
put that all in the thing i melted it i
put it in all the stuff and then i
basted the thing i then you had to put
an apple you had to put a lemon you had
to put like
all the rest of the herbs inside then i
had this turkey and
thing ready to go i woke up in the
morning nervous and scared
put it in but it came out great so we
had a good uh
mm-hmm it was great right it was great
the whole thing was saying although
thanksgiving itself was great so i hope
everybody else out there had a great
thanksgiving because we had a great
thanksgiving so i don't know if you've
ever if you have your own experience
uh your first thanksgiving experience
you know write in the comments from me
so i can see what that's all about
you know or send me your messages on
instagram whatever let me know about
your uh
your you know your first time you as an
adult had your first thanksgiving so
i know what i would do differently but i
think it's a tradition you know we got
going on and we should continue it you
know
yeah i loved cooking actually it was a
little stressful i was like oh i have to
make three things
and because you had to work too that day
that's why you were like yeah but she
still did it that's what she's a boss
made three dishes the same day
left for work for me to cook the thing
and then we woke up in the morning we
were like dancing in the kitchen and we
figured it out
i even made breakfast still too so it
was good yeah we have it all on video
we just need to put it together so maybe
we'll release it and that'll be on our
page on the patreon
um uh there's so make sure you look out
for that
uh you know if you go to the the links
have it down below
the link down below so go to the patreon
we're trying to put more personal videos
on there
so that was fun so anyways that was our
thanksgiving and it was great
so we are moving you know rachel hates
my place you know we don't need to go
into it you know it's her place now too
because she lives here but you know it's
my place
right so she hates it the kitchen she
can't stand the shower she hates the
water pressure right
you want to go [ __ ] about i don't think
it's your place until you're on the
lease so i'm officially on the new lease
so it's our place officially
whatever and so we went i'm so excited
we went we checked the water pressures
three floors
we don't need to know all the business
they don't need to know the whole
explanation of what the place is but
we found a new place it's nice we're
moving to it i'm saving money to buy a
home and we'll do that in a few years
but for now we got this nice place we're
gonna do it
and uh it's nice right you like the the
water pressure in the thing is great the
showers are big they got his and her
sinks there's it's spacious you
know so uh kitchen is nice like i can't
wait to
cook in this kitchen i'm looking forward
to that you know
but then um you know rachel got crystals
so that's what all this nonsense is
right here well i thought
the perfect way to start our
journey together into this new
home was to
[Music]
put some good vibes good energy into it
from the start and i've always dreamt of
having a place that i could put
crystals i've never had like
my own place since college oh wow
so so now you get these crystals yeah
so yeah but i'm excited so i'm here to
tell you why i'm so excited about it
okay talking to the mic
though and what they mean okay we'll
just go one two three four
let's go one at a time okay i have it
written in my phone so let me just
all right so here's this crystal that
looks like a dude this is very phallic
i'm i'm wondering why she got this one
because this is very like this is a
little dick right here
okay um describe the color
what it looks like it's like a lavender
uh crystal
you know please don't drop it i'm not
i'm not why are you assuming i don't
know
you just have your hand like i got it
woman
okay jeez i'm not gonna drop so this
one's like lavender
uh okay now let me describe it
okay this is called a spirit quartz
it's light purple and smoky
and sparkly yeah it
is considered a master healer the spirit
quartz protects and shields one's aura
this crystal will also heal and repair
damaged auras caused by a toxic and
malicious people it will purify all
chakras and harmonize all energy in the
body to assist us in reaching the spirit
world
spirit quartz is a stone that works well
in a group setting either social
sporting events or at work
especially service jobs due to it
bringing prosperity and
abundance to a group of people with
collective vision spirit courts
facilitates bonding in home environments
especially when a new member joins the
family
okay it stimulates healing and peace in
homes with fear
sibling rivalries and reduces resentment
and jealousy when
step families merge or when older family
members must give up their home to move
in
so i thought i mean i didn't really know
what the meanings were when i picked
these crystals even though
it would sound good if i did but like i
was being honest
i was just finding the crystals that
spoke to me the most that i felt like i
needed in my life
and so like this little dick one well
once i read what it was about it kind of
makes me think like okay we're going
into a new home we're merging families
all right
like it's just good energy for good
groups for both sides of the family
whoever comes to our home
all right so there's that lavender
crystal so that's going to be and what
room is that going to go in
i don't know maybe the living room
because it's good group situations or
maybe your podcast
room we'll see oh that's true too right
okay what about this one
and this one is like uh looks like it's
got it's brown with gray
and there's it's very like shiny and
sparkly but it actually looks like
like just dirty okay well
it's called a smoky citrine
it is a mixture of gold and yellow
citrine
and golden smoky cords
smoky core so this complementary
complementary combination is very
powerful
particularly in terms of grounding the
high vibration of the gold ray
into the body physical or grounding
smoky citrine may be considered a
superior crystal in terms of
manifestation
neither the smoky or citrine aspects
hinder each other's prosperities rather
they work in perfect harmony with each
other for instance the smoky aspect can
draw
negative energy from the self and the
citrine aspects will
cleanse and transform the energy into a
positive state
ready to ready for one to use in an
enlightening way so
manifestation
and what did i say um i think we got it
we don't need the whole explanation for
every single one just kind of like a
brief
well they say with that you're supposed
to really just breathe like
look at the gold and breathe it in
breathe the gold in yeah breathe the
gold in and it should give you a warming
effect okay
so there's that one that's the gold
digger special
wow just kidding you know we don't think
that
okay this one's the most what um
like breakable the most breakable it
looks like
really a blob of dog poop okay i could
see that
it also to me looks like coral okay
yeah all right yeah but it just looks
like something like crystallized
dog [ __ ] is what it looks like but this
one's like which one what does this one
do
okay this gives me one or two sentences
we don't need the whole is
the crystal background vanite or
it's a stone known for facilitating and
expanding the mental process while
also promoting action and production
okay there you go
so it's good um oh okay for
long hours of work this should go in the
podcast room then
or when i'm gaming yeah and
it actually stimulates sexual energy and
can
assist anyone who may have trouble
getting aroused so maybe not
in your room
maybe in the bedroom this one's going
into bed
it allows one to connect to that
animalistic
side that may have been locked away due
to inactivity so
like since maybe a coronavirus or
something all right
so this is and it harmonizes well with
other crystals and enhances its and
vibration so i like it i like it now all
of a sudden you like this
yeah i i mean i like that what you're
saying about it okay what about this one
this one looks like baby blue yeah
that's blue calcite
okay um it's known to calm emotions
and i've talked about this i think
before on maybe the first podcast
i don't know um this is a new one you
just got though
no it's not this one is the one i had
but okay we'll leave that there
then i've got them all from the same
place
all right yeah she went to san diego and
visited her brother who moved to san
diego
and she got like all these crystals for
the new place so yeah so we're going to
have all this like
chakra healing i don't really care about
you i mean i don't know well i don't
you love it i love it so it doesn't
matter i just love looking at it
it it helps my anxiety
it it lets me feel like
um everything's okay when i
look at it well hopefully everything is
gonna be okay um
you know like i say we're moving pretty
soon so i'm excited about that
um one of the things other things i
wanted to like talk about just some
stuff about rachel and i which is just
crazy like so rachel has this thing
where i have to take a shower
well we have room for it before i go to
bed we both have to take a shower and we
both have to brush our teeth
because rachel will not brush her teeth
and that's not even it
she's just lazy she just will be like i
didn't brush my teeth who cares i'm
going to work i have a thing on
a mask so it doesn't matter you know and
so and it's not
the problem that's not even that either
it's just like i wait
i'm like a procrastinator so like i
wait to the last minute to wake up for
work so like i just like
i know it's a little gross but i'll just
like
get up put some clothes on and run out
the door and then get coffee and food
and i feel like
even when you brush your teeth in the
morning after you have coffee and food
your breath still
smells like coffee and the food you ate
well you never really have like
like and then i just come home and
shower and brush my teeth
you never really have like breath where
i'm like oh my god
so that's probably probably the thing
too where she just had the princess
breath at all times
i mean i should know better
no but she has this thing where like
she'll like so now like
i used to not take a shower at like i'm
not a nice shot i like to take a shower
in the morning
but she's one of these like you got to
take a shower so it don't matter
what time of day like well okay everyone
knows that a man
sweats and like they don't know they
sweat we know
they're like no the whole day goes by
and you sweat and then you come home and
then
i'm like supposed to like cuddle with
you and you're just like a little greasy
that's that's what she says to me i was
like get your greasy paws off me your
face is greasy
your hair is greasy so then after like
well you have this golden glow
of just like of those like
lights that you use for your podcast oh
my god so i'm greasy so that i have to
like
so yeah that's our thing so like so now
i do but you know every time i just
think it's very important
mental health physical health
cleanliness
is very important i always feel better i
think it's good that
we both motivate each other to be better
people
for just society in general yes
if not for kissing yes well yeah that
helps too
you know even though like i don't know i
like all her smells yeah we like dirty
[Laughter]
you're you're hitting this and okay
sorry i saw the noise of this kid the
people
people could be complaining they're
gonna be like what's that noise but
that's what that was her cheers hitting
this
but anyways i'm not excited i know that
stone is working
ah this is just the sex stone was
working so we got to go actually
[Laughter]
yeah i'm taking this
no but i gotta you'll have to get a
smaller one
so then you could put it in your pocket
and carry it with you for sex at all
[Laughter]
my sex stone i see listen i have my wand
this is my from harry potter no you know
what this this lady in
ten where was i in um mulberry nashville
one of the waitresses at the nashville
comedy club she makes these so she heard
me talking about harry potter
and she said i make wands and she and
she gave me one and here it is
oh it looks great yeah that's right so i
have we have crystals and we have my
wand
but anyway guys i want to thank my girl
for coming on again and i want to thank
everybody for listening and watching
subscribing make sure you catch me on
eric griffin gaming daily on twitch and
i put those videos on youtube
and then hopefully you know in a couple
more weeks uh
actually the podcast it'll probably look
the same i'm thinking of getting a new
background for the new place you think i
should
comment below should we do a yeah should
i have a completely new look in a new
place or it's like you don't even need
to know because it's going to be like
this anyway so who who
who even cares we'll figure it out yeah
you could do it exactly
yeah exactly no one would even know you
moved
um but i'm really excited about that you
know i've been at this place for a long
time so it's like
i do like going to a new place you know
with my lady and we're going to be like
have our place but anyways thanks for
sharing subscribing
uh thanks for being a part of the
podcast uh all your comments and all
that stuff i love all that and uh you
know thanks for
supporting roofing with griffin you
could find more content
coming more on the patreon and like i
said i'm on air griffin gaming daily on
twitch and then i put those videos on
youtube
and every week i on mondays right after
the podcast
i stream on youtube to gaming so make
sure you go check that out right after
this
and thanks again to my lovely lady
rachel for being on the podcast she's
going to thanks for having me again
it was my pleasure we'll figure out what
else we'll talk about next time but uh
thanks for watching griffin griffin and
i'll see you next week
you